Je me sens jeune, je me sens frais, je me
sens en forme, je
ne pense pas à l'âge, je ne pense
à aucune limite
[Musique] c'est
là que j'ai joué certains de mes premiers
coups de tennis, les trous que vous voyez et
les murs sont  la conséquence des
bombes lors des attentats
[Musique]
Je suis né et j'ai grandi dans un pays petit mais
fier qui a traversé des
moments difficiles au cours des dernières décennies, c'est
pendant cette période difficile que
le sport est devenu partie
intégrante de ma vie  tout
a changé pour moi quand j'ai vu Pete Sampras
triompher et Wimbledon, il est devenu mon idole.
Je rêvais d'être comme lui le
joueur de tennis numéro un au monde
[Musique]
évidemment 2011 a été la meilleure année
jusqu'à présent pour moi  carrière et ça va être très
difficile de répéter ce que j'ai fait et
mais regarde, je l'ai fait une fois pourquoi pas deux fois
[Musique] [
Musique]
Je crois que nous, en tant que joueurs de tennis et
athlètes, faisons partie d'un sport aussi mondial  Je
dois me sentir responsable de
retourner vers les personnes qui ont besoin d'aide,
en particulier les enfants que vous connaissez, et de
contribuer aux programmes sociaux
autant que possible
en ce moment. J'essaie de prendre le
temps libre de la saison officielle sans aucun
tournoi ces quelques semaines.  et
venir ici en Serbie pour rendre visite à ma famille
et à mes amis proches et bien sûr faire
partie du travail humanitaire
qui est très important pour moi dans ma
carrière.
[La musique]
être un modèle pour mes enfants
apporte également plus de responsabilités  le
court de tennis pour moi parce que je sais
qu'ils seront plus conscients en regardant
[Musique]
J'ai la chance de pouvoir gagner 15 tu sais, je sais qu'il y
a deux gars devant
moi maintenant dans tu connais l'histoire du plus d'
agneaux  mais tu sais, j'ai encore le temps de
ne pas me laver
[Musique]
en croyant que cette énergie supérieure et que
l'âme donne à te donner va
te donner la bonne réponse parce
qu'essentiellement nous recherchons tous l'amour,
le bonheur et l'harmonie [
Musique]
je veux dire 12  il y a des mois sur la table d'opération,
donc j'espère que c'était la dernière
opération que j'ai subie depuis plusieurs mois. Je
vivais mentalement des
moments vraiment difficiles et difficiles
sur le terrain où je
remettais tout en question et, vous savez, je
doutais vraiment aussi
[Musique]
Je compte toujours sur ma foi et j'essaie d'être
reconnaissant et compréhensif envers un
créateur et un plus grand pouvoir et une
aide universelle que nous recevons tous,
donc je vous sais que j'essaie de me rappeler à
quel point je suis béni et de ne pas prendre
des choses qui te sont acquises